we're going to look at how a conspiracy
theory gets oxygen and grows and grows
and it can very be very quickly become
so big
that even finding out it's not true
won't debunk it for the people
perpetuating it wait what am i what am i
talking about i'm going to show you i'm
going to show you the genesis of a
conspiracy some might say the oranges of
a conspiracy for lack of a better term
we're going to look at an interview on
the joe rogan podcast with a guy who is
he goes by the name hotep jesus i guess
his name is brian sharp but he goes by
hotep jesus
himself a spreader of conspiracy
theories of all kinds hotep jesus has
previously said that the atlantic slave
trade was a myth that the vast majority
of african americans are the original
native americans and many other
conspiracy theories okay hotep jesus
appears on the joe rogan program
and joe rogan brings up the the widely
debunked claim that australia was going
to pass a law
to ban anybody from growing their own
food you know how i grow my radishes and
my cukes and my zooks in the backyard
all of that stuff
the the claim from rogan is in australia
that would be against the law now it's
not true we're going to look at the clip
and i want you to really look at first
how long they spend talking about how
terrible it is that australia is doing
this until they get the idea to look for
an article
they can't find any articles and then
rogan goes oh man it it might not be a
real story but then hotep jesus says
even if it's fake
the fact that you thought it is probably
a warning that they're going to do it at
some point
and this is the epitome of
not finding evidence
fuels us believing it's probably true
because maybe the evidence is being
hidden that this is a genius and genius
in a terrible way clinic on
conspiratorial thinking and they spent a
bunch of this episode slamming so-called
fake news
and then they fell for it and they
perpetuated it take a look at this you
know i want to find out what this is but
i read something briefly and i didn't
get into the article but they were
saying that they were trying to pass a
bill that would outlaw you growing your
own food in australia oh my god
did you read that no it was a part of
australia i think it was new south wales
okay someone's trying to pass a law that
won't allow you to grow your own food
and they were saying well you could grow
your own food and what else the disease
was from your food so now rogan is
ridiculing
the things that the people
saying growing your own food as bad
supposedly said but the whole story's
fake now they're ridiculing imaginary
people it affects the population kills
us all oh we can't have that because
they pulled that car i want to know what
what their justification was but i'm
pretty sure it had to do with like
agricultural contamination or you know
like i mean you could justify it if
you're a real piece of [ __ ] you could
say well you know most pandemics have
come from agriculture animal agriculture
we can't have unchecked pig ownership
that's not fair we can you be growing
vegetables what have your vegetables
ever got in them and diseases
[Laughter]
[ __ ] creeps man
these [ __ ] creeps they they got a
good grip on people during the pandemic
they locked everybody down in australia
and then you know what we're going to
stop these [ __ ] from growing
their own food because that's how you
smoke out an anti-vaxxer and look at now
now the story is fake and it's now being
built up into this is part of the
control
you tell people you go crazy in
australia with covid you tell people
they can't go to the grocery store
and they can't grow their own food in
order to force anti-vaxxers to go and
get themselves vaccinated because
otherwise they'll starve it's a
three-layer conspiracy theory now all
based on nothing and now is when it
starts to turn and they go maybe we
should find some evidence that this
actually is happening
make you can't even go to the grocery
store anymore and you can't grow your
food no dependent take that shot [ __ ]
can you find anything you are now
dependent upon
passes bill i mean i know what to look
for i'm just it's not nothing's coming
up uh the closest thing i could find was
something like this i don't that's not
what food no it's not it's not in new
zealand it's in uh it's in australia i
know but this is close new zealand is
like right around the corner could have
right um doesn't matter that rogan's
talking about australia if they find it
in new zealand it's close enough but
it's not there either ah it's got to be
a real thing it seems too good to not be
it's it's obviously um
outlaw growing food in australia and
nothing not a single thing comes up uh
oh
hold on except for that which was a
false thing
growing your own food they want they
want us
completely
dependent
so hotep now he's unfazed by the fact
that there's no evidence of the story
he's like this this is part of them
wanting us dependent
yeah i can't find it either damn it
it better not be fake
it might be fake
but that even if it's fake right like
the fake is usually the warning
[Music]
even if it's fake the fake is usually
the warning
that's like the
that's the epitome of these people if
they had found an article saying this
was happening in australia the article
would be the proof
they didn't find the article
so it was a fake story
now that's the proof it's probably
coming because the fake stories usually
come before it becomes a real story it's
the warning
this is unbelievable and almost three
minutes half of which is just building
on
they don't want to let you grow their
own food well that's not true
the reason they don't want to do it is
to smoke out anti-vaxxers to force them
to go and get vaccinated by making them
unable to grow their own food and not
letting them go to grocery stores unless
they're vaccinated so that's layer
number three layer number three this is
part of the general they want to control
you and they want you to be dependent oh
it turns out it's not real oh well it
doesn't matter it's probably the fact
that you thought it was
is a sign that at some point it will be
and one of the most brilliant things is
as rogan starts to realize it's fake
the guest doesn't care and hotep jesus
is like filling the dead air by saying
they want us dependent they want to
control us he's not even reacting to the
fact that there's no story he just keeps
going filling the dead air and it hits
all the points of conspiratorial
thinking including that the absence of
evidence rogan thought it they find no
evidence that's part of the conspiracy
that's probably a sign that it's coming
it is textbook clinic on this stuff and
by the way they almost seem disappointed
that it's not true it would be terrible
if you weren't allowed to grow your own
food they should be overjoyed oh my god
what great news you can grow your own
food in australia you can do it they're
not overjoyed they're almost like bummed
out
that the story is not real unbelievable
stuff
scary and probably a bunch of people
still came away from that believing that
it's true that australia won't let you
grow your own food scary stuff
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video